I think that all people should be taught
what their rights are before they
encounter police officer it's something
you should know
and you should not start thinking at the
moment when suddenly there's the police
officer oh I wonder what my rights are
so it's just a good thing for everybody
to know as part of their basic education
if you get pulled over it by the police
and you don't know why I think the most
important thing that a lot of people
don't know is to be polite on the one
hand but on the other hand you do have
certain rights in that situation the
police are not actually supposed to pull
people over for no reason under the
Fourth Amendment which is our protection
against unreasonable searches and
seizures the police do have to have some
reason to stop somebody to interfere
with their liberty so you could ask the
officer why am I being pulled over if
you're in a car or why you're why am I
being stopped if I'm if you're on the
street if the officer does have a
probable cause to arrest you or you know
to give you a tick ticket or something
like that then you know that's something
that presumably will happen but you do
have a right to go about your business
if in fact the officer does not have a
particular reason to stop you if the
officer is just stopping to say hey how
are you doing or what are you doing in
this neighborhood you do then have the
right to just say I'm fine thank you and
just walk on and you also do have the
right if the officer questions you have
a right to to be silent and you know to
not say anything so I think a lot of
people don't know if an officer says
will you answer the following questions
or do you mind if I search the trunk of
your car
or what's in your briefcase I think most
people feel that they have to cooperate
and say yes but in fact if the officer
is just asking then you do have a right
to say no if the police have probable
cause to arrest somebody that means
they've seen you speeding or they have
some other reason to believe you've
committed a crime at that point they do
have the right to arrest somebody and to
also do what's called a search incident
to the arrest of the person and of their
vehicle if they're driving a vehicle and
at that point if somebody tries to get
away once they're properly being under
arrest that's resisting arrest and
that's a crime however if an officer
does not have probable cause to arrest
somebody then you know that person is
gonna have a right to walk away because
there
under arrest it's not resisting arrest
if officer just would like to ask you to
consent to a search or something like
that and you say no I don't want to
consent at that point you do have the
right to walk away that's not resisting
arrest it's not obstruction of justice
it's just exercising your constitutional
rights
but there's a caveat here because the
Supreme Court has not been so good first
of all at the fact that the police
should really be explaining to people
what our rights are the other thing that
the Supreme Court says is that if you
don't just walk away if you run away
from the police that added to very
little else might be considered to be
suspicious enough to then give the
police more ground for intervention so I
think the important thing for people to
remember during any encounter with the
police is remain calm remain respectful
but also assert your rights because you
do have those rights and the mere fact
that the police don't tell you what your
rights are doesn't mean you don't have
them it just means you have to know on
your own what your rights are
you